I the Lord of Light by the way
Melisandre is religion there which was
referenced in the previous thing again I
don't try to do direct things from
history but I'm certainly inspired by a
lot of real history and the the the
religion of Lord of Light is based in
part on a couple of de dualist religions
that actually existed in our world one
of them the zoroastric Azure I can never
say that so a stream yeah whatever that
is yes and the other one the the Cathars
were the alba Jensens who were destroyed
they were Christian heresy that
flourished in southern France and a
crusade was launched against them and
they were ultimately all wiped out in
order sometimes called Europe's first
genocide the famous famous statement
kill them all God will God will sort
them out actually dates back to the a
virgin Sea and Crusade when they
captured when the Crusaders the
Christian Crusaders capturing Alba
Jensen City but only half of the people
in it were Alba Jensen's the rest were
good Catholics and that one of the
people said well how do we they look
just like us how do we know who to kill
and the commander said and killed them
all god woman oh his own and that's
that's straight out of real history but
the Cathars were a very strange Hurra
see that make fascinating reading
because they were they were true
duelists I mean Christianity has this
concept of God and the devil but the
devil is definitely you know second
place he's not the equal to God he's
he's a loser and God permits him to do a
little things but in the end there's no
doubt who's gonna have who's going to
come out the Abba Jenson's it was a real
duelist system where they thought
there's a dark God and there's a light a
God of light there's a God of good and
God of evil and they're at perpetual war
and there they are equal and we don't
know who's gonna win but the interesting
part of it you know they I mean they
were a Christian heresy and their belief
was that Jesus was actually the son of
the the god of light and Sophia for he
didn't really have a real body that you
know here here where they were kind of
straying from Orthodox Catholic teaching
because the body that we all live in is
a creation of the god of evil and indeed
the world that we live in is a creation
of the god of evil and it was a fairly
persuasive argument especially in the
early Middle Ages because they looked
around and they said look at this world
that you live in where people you know
there's no justice there's no peace
people come by and kill you and rape
your women and burn your crops and the
Lord's can cut off your head in eight
times and you're gonna get all these
horrible diseases and you're gonna
sicken and die and and gonna be you know
in great pain and women bring forth
children and paint what kind of good God
would design this world obviously this
world has been created by the evil God
and the good God is is trying to get us
out of it and that was you know the
Catholics were shooted this argument by
killing them all so that makes
fascinating reading but that's that's
the seed from which the Melisandre is
Lord of Light comes that and though or
Astra which was similar but but I can't
pronounce I moved on